[Música]
nueva emisión de la entrevista de france
24 en español y en esta oportunidad
vamos a viajar hasta el cine para hablar
sobre un hecho histórico para este país
que marca un antes y un después para
muchísimas personas que han visto sus
derechos ampliados tras años de luchas y
es que luego de la aprobación y
promulgación en el año 2021 de la ley de
matrimonio igualitario
finalmente el 10 de marzo pasado las
primeras parejas del mismo sexo pudieron
casarse y nos acompañan para hablar hoy
ser y consuelo morales las primeras
mujeres que se unieron en matrimonio en
igualdad ante la ley chilena como antes
sólo podían hacerlo las parejas
heterosexuales palabra de consuelo en
primer lugar por supuesto felicitaciones
por su matrimonio y muchísimas gracias
por su presencia en france 24
y gracias a ti santiago por el gracias
es un placer tenerlas en la entrevista
bueno son pareja hace ya cerca de 17
años verdad habían accedido ya lo que
era la unión civil pero el matrimonio
igualitario va más allá no en términos
de derechos especialmente porque tienen
una hija no y esta nueva ley permite lo
que es la adopción y también la
afiliación de los hijos e hijas estamos
hablando de puntos claves no de esta
norma porque hasta este momento su hija
no tenía los mismos derechos que otros
niños del país o sea que esta ley viene
ampliar no sólo sus derechos sino
también y principalmente los de su hija
verdad
exacto comenzamos con pavle así les
parece
sí sí la verdad es que teníamos antes el
acuerdo de unión civil que está que
venía a suplir un poco la carencia de
derechos que tenían las parejas del
mismo sexo pero que estaba muy lejos de
ser un matrimonio igualitario entonces
con este matrimonio igualitario que
ampliaron los derechos
en verdad es una tremenda noticia para
nosotros para nuestra hija porque ella
solamente en este minuto figuraba tenía
una sola madre y en este minuto ya se
reconocía por consuelo y tiene dos mamás
así que felices por el logro en verdad
por el avance increíble que tuvo este
país
consuelo contrariamente a otorgar más
derechos creen que la bloquera la unión
civil fomentaba aún más las
discriminaciones
si la fomentaba porque
la unión civil sirve tanto para personas
homosexuales como también heterosexuales
pero en el caso de los heterosexuales
tienen un poco más derechos que las
personas homosexuales ejemplo si una
pareja heterosexual
firmar el acuerdo de unión civil y uno
de iu tienen hijos y uno de ellos
fallece sus hijos pasan a heredar y su
pareja pasa a heredar el patrimonio que
pudieron construir juntos en cambio un
mismo ejemplo pero con una pareja
homosexual que tienen hijos
el hijo va a estar reconocido por la
madre gestante en este caso hablando de
dos mujeres y fallece la madre no
obstante el hijo no ayudaba nada del
patrimonio porque legalmente no estaba
reconocido por la madre que no era
gestante entonces si discriminada
absolutamente bueno su hija josefa tiene
dos años verdad si no me corregirán
ustedes durante todo este tiempo pabla
sufrieron algún tipo de discriminación
por parte de las instituciones chilenas
mira hasta sus 2 años no hemos sufrido
nunca ningún tipo de discriminación un
poco
agradecidas de la pandemia que para este
caso nos ayudó bastante porque en josefa
nació un mes antes de que comenzara la
pandemia entonces tuvimos prácticamente
los dos años encerradas
así que por lo menos en las visitas
médicas pero no tenemos problemas pero
siempre teníamos estar explicando el
caso de jose hasta que ella tenía dos
mamás en términos por ejemplo si me más
lejos en el médico qué
teníamos que explicar que el material
genético de costes para era del consuelo
entonces cualquier
pregunta con respecto al historial
médico tenía que ser a ella no a mí
entonces en estas cosas
era un poco tedioso pero nunca menos que
claro quizás no tanto discriminación
sino más bien obstáculos y dificultades
verdad que han tenido que vivir ahora
con sólo su familia entonces no era
reconocida como tal podría decirse no
por mucho tiempo la familia o mejor
dicho las familias no eran como una
suerte de privilegio no como un derecho
reservado sólo para algunas personas
para los heterosexuales principalmente
sentían que llegaría a este momento
finalmente y como vivieron aquel 10 de
marzo
la verdad es que no sé no pensamos no
imaginamos que iba a llegar este día de
hecho nosotros teníamos como nuestra
carta bajo la manga un plan de para
poder tratar de
reconocer a josefa ambas
con unos resquicios legales casi en
chile precisamente porque no pensábamos
que este momento iba a llegar nunca
entonces cuando cuando finalmente en
diciembre se aprobó y se promulgó la ley
fue algo que no creíamos y también
casualmente coincidió con que con el
tema de la polarización política que
había con el tema de las elecciones
presidenciales entonces estábamos con un
miedo tremendo de que fuera a salir un
presidente abiertamente homofóbico y que
fuera echar por tierra todos los lo poco
que se había avanzado y cuando
finalmente este esto se materializó y ya
efectivamente nos pudimos casar el 9 y
10 pues hacer realidad un sueño
con suelo bueno hablabas de un
presidente de derecha no en referencia
por supuesto al ex mandatario chileno
sebastián piñera pero ahora chile está
ingresando en una nueva era política no
está viviendo varios cambios importantes
no sólo a nivel político como decíamos
tienen un nuevo gobierno con un tinte
más quizá más progresista no más de
izquierda con gabriel boric y también
una convención constitucional que está
redactando una nueva constitución que va
a reemplazar a la que heredaron de la
dictadura de augusto pinochet y es una
convención con cierta diversidad y con
representación el fbi cum ha habido un
cambio a nivel social y cultural que en
chile que se tradujo en estos hechos hay
menos homofobia quizás
yo creo que hay menos como fobia o
quizás hay más aceptación a la
diversidad que existe en la sociedad
porque en casos de homofobia hay
diariamente
hoy día la mañana de hecho leía uno yo
creo que hay más aceptación a la
diversidad que existe dentro de la
sociedad como si podemos lógico siempre
han existido pero en este minuto en
chile las personas son más tolerantes a
los diversos y son más conscientes de
que hay diversidad y que se tiene que
convivir
en 32
para esta fue una conquista histórica
verdad pero quedan deudas pendientes
todavía
yo creo que la deuda pendiente está más
en la sociedad ya en términos legales
estamos
en igualdad de condiciones el tema ahora
es
reforzar
como decía consuelo el tema social de
que no haya tanta homofobia en el país
todavía todos los días hay muchos casos
de violencia en contra de los
homosexuales de los trans hay
violencia en las parejas que no son
tratadas aún como violencia
intrafamiliar
solamente se tratan como riñas ahora
esta ley yo creo que tiene que trabajar
en
tratar de ampliar la mentalidad de la
gente yo creo que estamos recién
empezando a esta tarea
para que realmente haya igualdad en el
país
ahora consuelo algo que has dicho en
alguna oportunidad es que bueno algo que
las motivó a contraer matrimonio ha sido
por supuesto como decían su hija josefa
pero algo que también las motivos pues
fue poder ser ejemplo para otras parejas
no romper con el estigma no fueron tus
palabras en este sentido o qué
repercusiones ha tenido su matrimonio no
sé si les han llegado mensajes etcétera
si de hecho no han llegado a mí no le
preguntaba paula pero he tenido varias
solicitudes de seguidor en instagram
felicitaciones en general de hecho hasta
en mi trabajo yo trabajo la
municipalidad la pintana también me
saludaron el fanpage y en general a mí
igual me gusta leer los comentarios que
hacen la gente
y han sido mayoritariamente positivos
más que cosas negativas las cosas
negativas que le digo hasta ahora son de
fanáticos religiosos o lo hay en todos
lados pero en su mayoría han sido
felicitaciones así es que contentas
también por ese lado porque igual al
exponerse así como lo hicimos nosotras
también uno siente un poco de temor por
las consecuencias que pueda traer esta
misma exposición pero hasta ahora no ha
pasado nada malo
y el resultado de unas cosas positivas
nosotros empezamos a hacernos visibles
como familia con la fundación iguales
que fueron los que los que llevaron esta
banderita de lucha y nos invitaron a
participar y desde el minuto uno
nosotras estuvimos dispuestas porque
sentíamos que había que ponerle cara a
al matrimonio igualitario que había que
ponerle
había que personalizarlos más para que
la gente pudiera también identificarse
con los casos y ver que somos personas
como cualquier otra
sin ninguna diferencia entonces
esa fue la principal motivación que nos
llevó a participar más activamente en
esto
habrá alabanza hace un momento de la
necesidad de un cambio cultural y social
durante creo que bueno ya hay avances a
nivel legislativo en este sentido crees
que esto podría sentar las bases para
influir a nivel no sólo por supuesto a
nivel judicial legal y lo que es más
operativo sino que podría influir en la
sociedad chilena
digo verlas a ustedes porque la bilis a
visibilización ayuda verdad
claro o sea esa fue la mayor
conversación que tuvimos con consuelo
cuando la fundación a través de ella
comenzó a
a preguntarnos si queríamos visibilizar
nuestras familias para
[Música]
para en el fondo hacernos como un poco
la cara del movimiento
nuestra conversación fue vez desde un
principio sí creo que
visibilizar es la forma más fácil de
llegar a la gente de de hijas romper ese
estigma que hay aquí en chile de las de
las familias homoparentales y lengua
maternal es por eso estamos
100% disponibles para para cualquier
persona que quiera hablar de nuestra
familia
para rajoy ser consuelo morales
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de france 24 ha sido un
placer dialogar con ustedes
[Aplausos]
gracias a ustedes una vez más a nuestra
audiencia le invitamos a que sigan
informando se en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto en
france24 punto com sigan con nosotros
[Música]